camille comme beaucoup de ma génération
nous a beaucoup marqués personnellement
il m'a vu arriver ici en tant que
pigiste et puis à prendre tant que
rédacteur en chef le plus beau souvenir
que j'ai c'est de khamis était hier
lorsqu'il les parties dans pour faire ce
faire le match d hier soir en me disant
mon cou talents comme d'habitude comme
tous les jours comme tous les week-ends
il m'a dit je reviens demain tu as ton
blog sport ne t'inquiète pas equiterra
en encore en dehors du fait que c'était
un véritable métronome au niveau du
travail et surtout un bureau de travail
c'est surtout quelqu'un qui avait
beaucoup de coeur et qui systématique -
telle 1 avec nous pour les moments les
plus difficiles et je retiens moi de vue
de camille à la fois ce côté un peu
j'avais dire bourru mais tellement
tellement tellement énorme au niveau 2
de l'amour qui portait pour pour la
rédaction de martinique 1ère es et son
attachement à ces stations
donc voilà